-Actor Anthony Rapp
told reporters this weekend
that when he was 14 years old,
Kevin Spacey made
sexual advances towards him.
Spacey apologized on Twitter,
blaming the event on
inappropriate drunken behavior
and writing...
One of our writers, Jenny Hagel,
is here to comment
in a segment we call
"A Lot of Problems."
♫♫
-Thanks, Seth.
I´m gay, and as a gay woman,
I have a lot of problems
with Kevin Spacey´s statement.
First problem --
it is inappropriate to respond
to an accusation of pedophilia
by saying, "I´m gay."
Those two things
are totally unrelated.
The only
appropriate response to,
"You tried to have sex
with a 14-year-old,"
is, "I am also a 14-year-old."
Let me be clear.
Coming out is a courageous
act of honesty,
not a justification
for a crime you committed.
That´s why no one goes to court
and says, "I plead gay"...
or enters the legal term
"gabeas corpus."
Second problem --
Gay people
are constantly working
against the incorrect stereotype
that we are sexual predators.
It´s a stereotype
that has followed us around
for generations,
and it´s totally unfounded,
and Kevin Spacey´s statement
sets us back.
This is worse for gay people
than when NBC canceled
"The Golden Girls."
But don´t worry.
You can still see it on
TV Land, Lifetime,
Hallmark, Amazon, Logo,
and at my friend Philip´s house,
because he has the box set.
Gay people
are actually less likely
to be pedophiles
than straight people.
That´s an indisputable fact --
like 2 plus 2 equals 4
or "K-PAX" has
a 41% on Rotten Tomatoes.
Third problem --
Kevin Spacey blamed his actions
on drunken behavior.
That makes it sound like
every gay person
is two beers away
from molesting a kid.
I´m not.
I´m two beers away from singing
"Come to My Window" at karaoke.
And three beers away from
singing it from my window.
Fourth problem --
the phrase "I choose now
to live as a gay man."
Oh, now you choose
to live as a gay man
after you threw us all
under the bus?
That´s like saying, "I told
everyone you´re an asshole.
Now I choose to come
to your dinner party."
Too late.
You´re not invited anymore.
The gay community
has been made up
of brave, brilliant people
like Alan Turing
and Audre Lorde
and Billie Jean King.
You´re not in the gay community.
You´re in the creep community.
Go celebrate creep pride
and throw a little creep parade
and leave us out of it.
Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Also -- Also, "I choose now
to live as a gay man"?
You don´t choose to be gay.
That´s not how it works, son.
Do you think I choose
to be rejected by my church
and own three pairs
of cargo shorts?
You´re born this way.
Even a woman in a meat dress
knows that.
Being gay is a rich
and amazing life experience.
Assaulting a 14-year-old
is a crime.
Don´t confuse the two.
And whatever you do,
don´t watch "K-PAX" on Netflix.
This has been
"A Lot of Problems."
[ Cheers and applause ]